hello there from cop 26 here in glasgow
it's time for the press preview a first
look at what is on the front pages of
tomorrow's papers uh time to see what's
making those headlines tonight with the
political editors of the sun and the
daily mirror harry cole and pippa
carrera they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight great to see
you here in glasgow we'll chat in a
second first of all let's see what's on
some of those front pages we're going to
start with the guardian
reporting that world leaders have agreed
a deal to reverse global deforestation
at today's cop 26 climate summit here in
glasgow that news breaking this evening
well the telegraph leads with her
majesty's message to world leaders at
the conference urging them to
rise above politics
in fact it's also the top story for the
times their headline answer the call of
future generations urges the queen
onto harry's paper the sun going with
the monarchs tribute to the work of her
late husband the duke of edinburgh in
raising awareness about climate change
height of hypocrisy i think i said that
how they ended it the metro looks at the
use of private jets by billionaires
heading for cop 26. they're yachts as
well
moving away from the summit the mirror
leads with an interview with an assisted
dying campaigner who chose to take her
own life after suffering from a
long-term illness
so harry and pippa here with us this
evening great to see you it's been a
busy old day here in glasgow hasn't it
why don't we start with the front page
of the daily telegraph in fact most of
the papers uh going with that uh video
message from her majesty a great shame
that she can't be here in person she
wanted to be here she was told to rest
by doctors so instead she gave a video
message for delegates and leaders which
they heard at around hopper 7 tonight
looking rather wonderful in green of
course what did you make um harry of
that message i thought it was rather
poignant actually absolutely obviously
the queen has been unwell uh we know
she's been told to rest by doctors hence
why she's not here i thought it was a
really touching moment in that speech
where in the video message where she
says you know none of us are going to
live forever and i think it's the first
time we've really heard
monic uh talk in those terms obviously
she lost her husband this year and she
lays on the the praise
it's an incredible moment actually we
don't very well see her majesty speak in
such honest and candid terms about her
own family and she very poignantly calls
out prince charles for taking on that
mantle that philip started 50 years ago
talking about the environment and prince
william and rather pointedly we point
out tomorrow they mentioned prince harry
who um is a keen environmentalist talks
about nature and africa and elephants
all the time but a small snub there but
um no a really dramatic moment today um
you've got the you know you had david
attenborough you had boris johnson you
had various world leaders but there's
just one that everyone pauses and
listens to because she's met them all
she's seen them all and she knew for the
last you know better half of the last
century and um no it was it was it was
sad she wasn't here to do it herself
yeah i thought why don't we slide in uh
the front of the sun as well because as
you mentioned that tribute to
prince philip and a reminder really for
all of us about his uh green uh
credentials phil the green uh the
headline that uh the sun's gone for
people what did you make of what she had
to say do you think leaders here uh
really will listen to her i think so
having been in the opening ceremony
earlier when prince charles her son
stood up to speak people really paid
attention to what he had to say and you
can only think that when they were
gathering for that reception that rather
glittering reception later in the
evening that they would have all had all
the ears open to her video message and
of course this is not the first we've
heard from the queen on cop a few weeks
ago she was overheard she was caught on
camera suggesting that she was fed up
with everybody or these leaders talking
about all the rhetoric but not actually
um coming up with any action and you
know that's clear if if perhaps in more
diplomatic terms in her video message
tonight it's clear that she really
thinks that they need to rise above
politics and that actually if you are
dealing with what the future brings and
thinking about future generations and
the the quote on the telegraph is um
is about the the world's children and
future then actually you need to show
statesmanship and you need to sort of
step back from the politics of the
situation the geopolitics of you know
whose economy is going to be powered by
coal and who wants to be at the the
front edge the leading edge of new green
technology um and all the other
different geo political issues which are
coming into play here and you need to
step back from it and take a a sort of a
much longer term approach to the
problems one of the biggest problems
that's facing us just now and there's
very few world figures particularly
politicians that could actually see
something like that and i think have the
credibility because of their length of
service and because of the long view
that they take on these sorts of issues
they they step back from the political
frame to do that and the queen is one of
them pip is absolutely right because
when you talk about you know we're going
to go net zero in 2050 or as modi said
today 2070
boris johnson made a joke about still
being prime minister when he's 95 but
actually it is kicking the can down the
road a little bit all these promises all
the politicians now who are in this room
might not be alive or might not be in
office at a time when actually these
things come through 120 exactly and it
does take a message from someone who has
been you know
such a prominent figure of the last half
century to go guys hang on it is a
little bit bigger than this thinking you
know and it she has this dignity and
authority which few elected politicians
will ever have and that is why she's
such a sort of secret weapon but even
that secret but such a powerful weapon
for britain to deploy on the world stage
and you think if this climate change
summit um which you know has all the
weight of expectation upon it without
the royal family the firm were out of
force today you had kate and wills and
camilla and charles and
everyone banging the drum for britain
without that you think would be a much
much weaker power in the world tonight
yeah let's bring in the inside pages of
the sun as well um the headline the
world is hot enough um which i'd rather
like to actually we've had some fun with
this today yeah the james bond sort of
uh analogy wasn't it saying that it's
like james bond sort of trying to uh
defuse a ticking time bomb um earth
peril like bond film he said it's like
defusing a a huge bomb and pippa do you
think boris johnson got the tone right
today when he made his speech well he
likes this metaphor don't doesn't he and
certainly at the start of the speech
when he launched into this whole spiel
about james bond there was a moment
where i sat there and kind of thought
oh i'm not sure if he's got the tone
quite right on this but he very quickly
you know he caught people's attention
and i guess if what he's trying to do
with these sometimes quite outlandish
metaphors is to get a spread on the sun
with a headline on that and reaching
readers that he might not other people
who might not other likewise reach then
i suppose it's job done but he very
quickly went into the sort of the more
serious stuff and the
um really the apocalyptic vision that
he's set out over the last few days of
if we don't get world leaders to somehow
work together to keep rises and global
temperatures down below the 1.4 or at
least at the 1.5 degree warming that
that we're planning for
then we're going to see flooding we're
going to see droughts we're going to see
whole island nations being lost as
cities descend under sea water and um
you know again he made the point
actually which the queen later did uh
about
about our not just our children but
their children in future looking back at
this moment in glasgow and saying that
this was the moment that we needed to
make history and we failed you mentioned
you mentioned prime minister modi
earlier i mean do you think he was
listening to the speech because many
here will be very disappointed in in his
pledge tonight
yeah i think the fact is he's he has
been brought to the table and i imagine
the the the 2070 offer isn't quite where
people wanted it to be you know even
russia or even china
are talking making noises about 2060.
obviously australia and britain have
signed up to 2050 it's a long way down
into the next into this century before
any change will happen i think modi's a
really interesting example because he is
playing to both a domestic audience a
country that's having a bit of a wobble
at the moment as well and the fact is
that the point he makes is
that actually you know countries like
britain and america who basically
invented this
this stuff we had we had a 200 year head
start on the industrial revolution we've
been pumping out 200 years worth of of
coal in uh burning coal and pumping
carbon to the atmosphere and actually
the point he makes to both domestic
audience and an international audience
is hang on we're playing catch up and if
we if you do want us to go faster it's
going to cost you money so you know
boris john's been doing the whip around
copper this year and the and the western
powers basically saying we need 100
billion a year and modi's come around
and said nice opening offer you know if
you want me to go faster you better pay
and maybe it'll change in you know in
two weeks time maybe he'll say well look
you've offered me this cash um i'll
bring my i'll bring my 2017. interesting
you see that british officials tonight
or earlier this afternoon were
suggesting that they want to see uh
india and china go further and
whether there's any sort of room for
maneuver in the next fortnight i think
they're quite pessimistic about but
certainly over the next 12 months and
and years following that and there was
even some suggestion that this 2050 date
that we've put that we've got in place
that we're all aiming for uh for net
zero emissions could be brought forward
if britain and other leading developed
nations say that perhaps 2045 then that
might encourage countries like china and
india to bring forward their deadlines
that it's not actually a fixed deadline
it's more of a starting point yeah and
we'll see how it evolves and also the
other thing of course is he did make a
pledge today about
green energy didn't he and the 50
percent um pledge to to get their power
from green energy which would be
fantastic listen we've only got a minute
left and i want to finish on this story
uh in the metro um talking about the
hypocrisy of uh some of the billionaires
who are here height of hypocrisy um
billionaires on their on their sort of
private jets and boats does it matter
that much isn't it more important the
fact that they're actually here that
they're speaking to world leaders that
they're trying to make uh get their
message heard isn't that a bit more
important than sort of cheap shots like
this is that a cheap shot i don't know
sure i think it's a very fair point
as someone who tried to get him on a
train yesterday and spent a better part
of 12 hours not getting here on a train
uh i can understand the pain look you
know the bezels
of this world are always going to be
held rightly to a very high account um i
think the billionaires and the
politicians the billionaires i have a
lot less time for sort of swapping up
here slightly greenwashing their
reputations and generally you know
trying to make themselves not be seen as
evil bond villains and billionaires
around the world politicians look after
you boris johnson was in rome he flew
here from rome there's a big debate
about whether they should fly back to
london and or get the train like the
rest of us um but i think
it is a bit of a sideshow when actually
some of the startling facts you walk
around this place listening to fringe
events and listening to speeches some of
the things that are going to happen in
the next 15 20 years makes us look a
little bit like a sideshow really quick
thought picture on this from you well i
think politicians particularly the ones
that are hosting the cops summit should
be shown leadership and i think the fact
that boris johnson is getting a plane
back down to london which is just a
four-hour train journey from glasgow
really isn't showing the sort of
leadership that you might expect
regardless of how green the fuel they're
using or whether the offsetting
offsetting the the the emissions i think
it sends out a bad message
okay uh people harry uh fantastic stay
where you are thank you very much indeed
coming up after the break we're going to
be looking at plenty more stories
including in the telegraph a cartoon
play on the words give a man a fish and
you feed him for a day teach a man two
fish and you annoy the french for a
lifetime talk about that
in a couple of minutes
[Music]
you're watching the press preview we're
live at cop26 in glasgow harry and pippa
still with us uh there's been an update
in the fishing story pippa do you want
to fill us in well this long running so
it feels like it's long running saga
probably
between britain and france over
post-brexit fishing rights we were early
this afternoon we had liz trust
suggesting that britain would retaliate
um to tomorrow morning if france went
ahead with threats to bring in extra
checks um on cross-border trade the
whole thing was about to erupt and then
there was talks in brussels the eu
arranged talks in brussels this
afternoon and early evening trying to
resolve the situation and it looks like
there's been um a suspension of
hostilities harry would say running up
the right flag probably on france's
behalf but who's actually this being
who's back down
they've given it 24 hours
tomorrow a ceasefire rather than
surrender i think we discussed over
dinner what we're gonna call it so
where's it gonna go next year hello back
into the back into where these things
always go into a sweaty down that you
know basement room in the european
commission where lots of video calls and
and and sort of you know for
smoke-filled rooms they used to be
called in politics but you know a back
and forth and a bit of movement and a
bit of a fudge on both sides i suspect
but macron's been tearing around for the
last you know a couple of couple of
weeks making these outlandish threats
they've come to a bit of a head as they
see the body language there then they're
not they're not they're not best buddies
as they have been previously
there's no denying that macron at the
beginning of the of last week was very
firm that tuesday would be when he
started to pull the lever on all these
various retaliation measures that he was
going to put in he found himself quite
isolated over over the weekend of the
g20 where he ran to the top of the hill
and realized the eu wasn't behind him
and he's slowly now climbing back big
big lunch and big talks in paris uh on
uh on thursday between lord frost whose
boris boris's sort of brexit henchman uh
and clement bone who's the sort of um
who's kind of
a little bit like the boris johnson of
uh
of uh french politics he's very
outspoken he's very clown and she's you
know he's he has a turn of phrase should
we say so um it will be one that runs
around okay and we'll finish with a
story that's also on the front of the
times actually uh this is another
ongoing uh rao if you can call it that
about gps and face-to-face appointments
what's the update there so there's a new
study by the university of cambridge
amongst
clinical experts suggesting that
the increase in
online consultations web consultations
in primary care has meant
a really quite serious decline in in the
level the standard of diagnosis and that
obviously
is a huge concern when you consider that
pre
uh pandemic we were the the numbers of
online consultations were tiny compared
to the numbers i think it's about 80 of
consultations are online initially
anyway at the moment and the big fear of
course is that there are serious
diagnoses which can only really take
place in person whether it's cancer
diagnosis whether it's something of
mental health where the gp really needs
to be in front of a patient or the
clinician he's been in front of a
patient that are being missed um 20
seconds
boris johnson can ride as high as he
likes in the polls now but two more two
or three more years of
of people being very very angry about
the nhs and that's the government's
always going to be in trouble yeah i
mean it's um it's a difficult one this
isn't it because for many people of
course the online system has been
working really well and it means you can
get an answer you can get a prescription
very quickly but it's for those who
perhaps aren't so savvy with the
internet or whatever
it's been lovely seeing you both in the
flesh hasn't it what a change rather
than speaking to you over zoom harry
potter thank you very very much